As Roger Federer prepares to retire,..
…unlike some,  the tennis champ tells Savannah Guthrie exclusively,...
…he's not looking for a do-over.
You know, unretiring is a thing now.
I know.
Tom Brady. Now, Serena seems to be wavering a little.
You're done?
No, no. I am definitely done. I know that, yeah.
41 years old, Federer will play his final professional games in the Laver Cup,...
…a team tennis event he helped create.
The capstone on a career that includes victories in every grand slam tournament...
…and an astounding 237 consecutive weeks at number one.
Is it one of those things where they say, sometimes, there's the stages of grief?
Did you feel all those feelings?
Yes, all of it.
And also the ones where I don't want to deal with it.
Like, I just don't want to think about it.
Don't talk to me about it.
I went through a lot of sadness and emotional moments where,..
…just, you know, how you start thinking about everything you're gonna miss.
And then, you just think, "Oh my god, my life's gonna be miserable after."
And then you realize, no, no, no actually we're gonna have more time,...
...so we're gonna do all these amazing things now.
So, it's gonna be great, you know.
The "we", his wife Mirka and their four children.
For us, a last chance to savor a game of grace and power.